so guys don't be too jealous of me right
now but literally I did kind of ask her
that she would do my makeup not thinking
she'd say yeah of course I were and she
said yeah this is what I do every day
but it's beautiful saying is like a day
and day I kind of want to push you out
of your comfort it out of your comfort
zone I want to try something really new
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to act your makeup just a little
bit I'm going to use I'm just our rose
gold palette just add a little couple
colors in there I'm really gonna take
you out of your comfort zone today oh
I'm ready I think I'm in safe hands with
you good care of it I really want to
give you kind of like a grungy sexy
still very you but kind of smoky look
this is so pretty on the bottom here
this is just sandal what I'm using you
have to use this every day
oh I love that name sandal it's not a
smell that you love everything you said
that you love sandalwood I read that and
loved it so I'm going to take a little
bit of a cocoa which is brown and I knew
you liked brown yeah I'm going to add a
little bit more to this water line here
so I'm like kind of obsessive putting a
little shimmer in the corner which one
you would like to use angelic is
sometimes called that that I said after
me yeah elegant not everyone's laughing
by the way not cool I'm using and this
is just the natural matte palette from
Too Faced which I love to use for my
brows and just an honest Asya spoolie
I'm just kind of filling in a brows a
little bit getting you a little bit of a
hooter like oh my god I'm getting a hood
a bra that is so cool cuz i do i do i do
nothing with my brows nothing no this is
your brows naturally yeah i mean i know
i do get some threaded but i don't do
anything and literally just adding a
tiny bit here so do you like powder and
brows more than like pencil i like
pencil but the only thing is like
sometimes i feel you'd be harsh I do
prefer matter
yeah yeah therefore natural I'm just
adding a little concealer I'm using
diesel Ava you can see there I know it's
like completely that's actually you know
that means that shows that that's what
you actually use I actually use
sometimes I love to use the bay and I
meet the eyes I just think it minimally
more underneath the eyes it's like a
really nice just neutral kind of color
with such a gorgeous power you can it's
like a vanilla color so let's get on
almost everyone well I think the blend
you've done here is just so clever
because you've got obviously all the
shimmers and kind of quite a lot of
ready
pinkey one and it's so flattering
because did you like have lots of
different color combos and then went
kept moving things that were you knew
what you wanted I knew exactly what it
was yeah I knew exactly that the next
problem that's coming out was a little
harder so now lashes this is like this
is the test though because I am the
choice I am like a lash virgin are you
really okay yeah well I'm using one of
our newer lashes it's called Noelle it's
kind of a double layer it's really
really pretty lashes foaming so it's not
really me but the fibers are really
amazing so I love them because they're
tapered at the end so they look so
pretty international so I'm just going
to go ahead and just try and measure
this up against your eye and since
you're a new lash where I'm going to
trim them a little bit like what are the
tips without for trimming so yeah I
definitely measured it and I trimmed out
like so you know just I took out with a
nice chunk of it I left like basically
this big chunk does being the end and
then I always like to like wiggle the
lash a little bit and then really
important is the glue the glue is
actually the most isn't the most
important most important part this is
where you're either going to like nail
it or you're going to hey lashes so I
kind of have like a general rule with
our glue and I'm sure whatever all goes
but I like to use just as much glue as
the thickness of the bands I basically
take however Signet the band power to
command is I take that exact amount of
glue so don't over glue no is that a big
no that's a big now now because if you
put too much glue what can happen is it
can become like so hard to actually glue
on because it'll move and it'll like
it's like forever drive so that's just
kind of like generally my rule so it's
just basically doubling the thickness
and I let it sit for a couple seconds
take a tweezer is the tweezer essential
not necessarily with with glasses now I
do like tweezerman but that's not
necessary so I'm just going to have you
look down and when have you turn just
laughing no and I'm literally just
pacing the glue on top of your eye I
mean they open up your eyes I don't
think you need it cuz your eyes are a
size big and beautiful but I want a
little bit of you
he's definitely opened up the eyes I
guess you could do it in your sleep
oh yeah Lee do you remember the first
time you used lunches yes
you actually remember you remember Ivan
whispers laughs I bought it was math
number five don't buy those lashes their
sugar mad added sugar addict and it was
actually JLo was the reason why I got
into lashes yeah cuz she was wearing
false lashes like in 2003-2004 she's
like one of the only celebrities and
really wearing them
okay I'm gonna holy oh my god this
palette it's going no English you to say
is life is how it really is life I'm
only going to add a little bit of hey
I'm not going to go to full step I'm
just going to add a little bit of C bit
a little bit natural and I'm just
putting it here on the higher part how
did you feel about highlighting no to
highlight your nose
I don't you can yeah it's too long other
but you totally can we can highlight
your nose yes please the thing with
highlighters is I often don't use them
because some of them are just too
sparkly don't you think yeah well yours
are gorgeous so we didn't put any
Sparkle in our highlight cut because I
feel like it looks a little bit more
luxurious and it looks more just a
little bit more natural to and it
doesn't have as much but I hate sparkle
hmm I actually like it on the eyes but
nama
on the face okay so I'm going to go this
is definitely taking you out you have a
zone this is a gray color and I'm kind
of just going to put it all over in the
beginning I wear in the office mostly
but I love it like it depends like on my
mood I feel like it definitely makes me
feel a little bit more badass Kevin
happy just turn straight towards me
right just the shape it's like the dirt
good I'm glad you said that
we put coconut in it so we're going to
that dry we're going to like completely
set it straight
I'm glad you're preparing yeah a gray
like I've never worked I know I would
never wear it normally but now I'm like
I'm obsessed the gray what are we adding
now oh so we're going to take the melted
strobe which you're the first person
outside of myself using this and it's
just gonna completely transform it so
the gray is like very strong so now this
is where we're going to get a little fun
with there's a new brand new product is
a brand new product basically this was
kind of an accident that we created it
was just like we were working with
developing and melted strokes for the
face and then this is
developed out of it it was just like a
gloss and it what it does is it really
just transforms the lip completely so
the very great right now it's kind of
very rocker like but you look I don't
know if you like if you as beautiful so
now what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to take this and put on top and
what this does is it is completely
transforms the colors so I'm going to
have you just look straight into the
camera and you can see like the middle
already is like completely working out
into like a little bit of a different
color so this is a transform where you
can use over any it just completely
transforms the clothes but even if you
see when I swatch it it has Lea these
really interesting iridescent pearls
that kind of come out to like pink and
gold and peach they just have really
amazing because when you plant up the
gray in particular it's just it's kind
of like it looks amazing so I'm just
going to quickly I'm gonna like let you
blot it really quickly it does it was
interesting so I'm just going to take it
like this and this is if you want to go
more matte and then what's left on your
lips is actually just the pros so it's
quite umbrella is a really cool concept
I took you out of your comfort zone
I mean hood uh there's there's me
there's comfort zone and then there's
taken comfort zone but I love it I know
what the thing is and are you a cool but
also you know it's stunning stuff but
also in our job you know we are always
about showing people different options
and like you know trying new things and
I definitely me as a journalist in the
magazine I'm always like get out of your
concepts I don't get out of your boring
beige Lane and I would stay in my boring
neutral agency you know okay so it's
nice for me to do something else how am
I going to go to the office share will
go to the off-planet jobs like yes but
am I going to wear this every day
probably not but I've learned but you do
look beautiful I mean honestly like I
think it's a great way to kind of
express like a little bit of attitude a
little bit of like this boldness but
while still keeping it beautiful I find
you let me do that thank you so much
Alexi Broderick okay for more videos
like this please make sure you guys
subscribe to glamour UK